สวัสดีค่ะครููชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensible ไยห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบ
ธรรมชาติค่ะแล้ววันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครู
ชิเเนี่ยก็มาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวัน
นี้คือวันอะไรคะครูชิวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ครูปุ๊อ่าวันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 6 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนแห่งความรักค่ะ
อุ้ยเดี๋ยวสิเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ค่ะปีพ.ศค่ะ
2567 ค่ะปีค.ศค่ะคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูชี้มาพบกับ
ทุกคนนะคะในวันอังคารที่ 6 เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะใช่ค่ะครูปุ๊บทีเนี้ยโอ้เวลา
ที่เรากินอาหารน่ะเราซื้อผักมาครูปุ๊ก
แล้วบางทีแมันเดี๋ยวๆผักอะไรคะครูชิผัก
สลัดผักเอ่อมะเขือเทศเอ่อแตงกวาอะไรคะผัก
อะไรอ่ะอย่างครูชิมีหอมใหญ่
ออหอมใหญ่ค่ะหอมใหญ่เนี่ยครูชิกินแบบอาจ
จะซื้อมามันมี 3 หัว 4 หัวเนี่ยจะใช้ไม่
หมดไงกินไปแค่ 1 ค่ะเหลืออีก 2 หัวแต่
เก็บไว้นานๆเนี่ยมันก็เสีย
ไงถ้าครูชิเนี่ยอยากจะเอา 2 อันนี้ไปปลูก
ได้มยอ่ะโหก็ต้องได้สิคะแต่ว่าบ้านกูชิ
เนี่ยมีดินมั้ย
เออปูก็ต้องใช้ดินใช่มั้ยเ้าปลูกแบบไม่
ต้องใช้ดินไม่ได้หรอใช้แต่น้ำ
อืมคิดว่าบางอย่างไม่ได้ค่ะเพราะอย่างหอม
เนี่ยมันมีน้ำเยอะถ้ามีน้ำเยอะๆมันอาจจะ
เป็นแบบอาจจะไม่ได้เป็นต้นหรือเปล่าไม่
รู้อาจจะเน่ามั้ยอุ๊ยคูชิเคยเห็นอ้าหรอ
จริงอ่ะใช่เค้าปลูกในน้ำเหรอคะเใช่ค่ะ
เค้าเอาหอมเนี่ยไปใส่ในขวดน้ำค่ะแล้วมัน
ก็มีรากงอกออกมา
ด้วยใช่ๆๆูปุ๊ก
โอ้โอ้โหก็ดีเพราะว่าเพราะว่าปกติแล้ว
เนี่ยพอพอเราเก็บไว้นานๆกุบปุ๊บบางทีมัน
มีต้นใหม่ขึ้นมาเลยนะเราอาจจะเอาไปลงดิน
ได้เลยนะออใช่มใช่ๆมันอาจจะงอกใบมันงอก
ขึ้นมาค่ะมันแทงเป็นใบขึ้นมาจากหัวใช่มย
แล้วก็มีใบใบสีเขียวใช่เนี่ยค่ะเก็บไว้
นานๆเนี่ยกลายเป็นแบบนี้เลยค่ะมีมีต้น
อ่อนๆโผล่ขึ้นมาแล้วก็รากเห็นมั้ยคะอัน
นี้รากใหม่นะคะไม่ใช่รากเก่าเห็นมั้ยราก
สีขาวๆอันนี้ยังไม่ได้ใส่น้ำเลยนะอืก็ไม่
ได้ใส่น้ำแต่มันยังมีความชื้นชื้นก็คือ
มันเหมือนมีน้ำอยู่ในอากาศหรือในตู้เย็น
หรืออะไรแบบนี้มันก็อาจจะทำให้มันน่ะโต
ได้นะเออแต่มันอาจจะโตได้ไม่ดีไงครูชิมัน
ไม่เหมือนลงในดินเพราะว่าดินเนี่ยมันจะมี
สารอาหารนะนเหมือนมีอาหารเหมือนคนก็ต้อง
กินข้าวนะไม่อย่างงั้นมันก็ไม่แข็งแรงค่ะ
รชินะต้นไม้ก็ต้องมีอาหารของต้นไม้จะทำ
ให้ต้นไม้เนี่ยโตแล้วก็แข็งแรงแล้วก็ดี
มากนะแต่ถ้าโตโดยที่ใช้น้ำอย่างเดียวไม่
มีอาหารเนี่ยมันน่าจะโตแต่ว่าไม่สวยไม่ดี
นะุคิดนะเพราะว่าูชิเคยเห็นเค้าบอกว่า
ปลูกปลูกต้นพวกเนี้ยเราไม่ต้องเราไม่ต้อง
ไปง้อดินเลย
ค่ะใช้แต่น้ำอย่างเดียวหรือไม่ก็เป็นพวก
หอมแดงอ่ะครูชิเคยเห็นในเอ่อเาปลูกแบบ
เนี้ยครู
ปุ๊กเอาหอมเยไปเอ่อมีมีกล่องพลาสติกที่
เราซื้อข้าวมากินใช่มั้ยเราก็เอามาเจาะรู
ค่ะแล้วก็เอาหัวหอมอมาวางอืมันก็จะมีราก
งอกไปข้างล่างเป็นน้ำข้างบนก็จะเป็นต้น
ใหม่ให้เราไง
อ๋อก็คือยังไงเขาก็ไม่เอาหัวหลงไปแช่ใน
น้ำเนอะไม่ใช่เอาต้นหอมไปแช่เอาหัวหอมเไป
แช่ลงไปในน้ำไม่ๆๆเา้าจะให้แค่ให้ให้มัน
งอกรากแบบนี้ค่ะเนี่ยค่ะรากมันจะงอกลงไป
ในน้ำแบบนี้อ่าก็ไปดูดน้ำมาเลี้ยงต้นใช่
พอต้นโตเราก็เอาไปกินแต่ครูชิเห็นมยล่ะสี
มันไม่ค่อยสวยไงแต่ถ้ามีดินเนี่ยโอโหต้น
เนี่ยขึ้นมาเนี่ยมันจะแข็งแรงแล้วก็มีมี
สีเขียวมากๆเลยนะกูิว่าเค้าอ่ะเอาไว้ใน
บ้านไม่ไปไว้ข้างนอกต้องมีแสงแดดอือมันก็
เลยสีไม่สวยไงสีแบบไม่น่ากินไม่แข็งแรง
ต้นจะเล็กๆใช่อ่าเพราะฉะนั้นมันอาจจะไม่
อร่อยเหมือนแบบไปปลูกกับดินเนาะใช่นะมัน
น่าจะมีอาหารดีขึ้นแล้วก็ต้นใหญ่แข็งแรง
นะอันนี้ก็เป็นดีนะถ้าเกิดว่าว่าเราอยู่
คอนโดมิเนียมเราอาจจะแบบไม่มีที่ดินเนาะ
ในการที่จะปลูกต้นไม้อืเราก็อาจจะทำแบบ
เล็กๆนะสำหรับเป็นเอามาทำอาหารกินอย่าง
เงี้ยนะอือทีเนี้ยการจะเราจะปลูกต้นไม้
อ่ะมันมีวิธีปลูกต้นไม้เยอะใช่มยหรือเรา
เรียกว่าการขยายพันธุ์อ่าขยายพันธุ์ก็คือ
จากพันธุ์ที่ต้นที่ 1 แล้วก็แบออกไปปลูก
ที่ 2 ที่ 3 ที่ 4 ที่ 5 ที่ 6 เนี่ยขยาย
ละมันเยอะขึ้นนะ 6 ต้นอย่างเงี้ยนะขยาย
พันธุ์ทำไมคะปลูกยังไงอ่ะครูชิอย่างแรก
เลยครูชิว่านักเรียนน่าจะรู้จักเนาการ
ขยายพันธุ์โดยการปลูกด้วยเมล็ดค่ะเอา
เมล็ดเราเรียกว่ามาเพาะนะเพาะก็คือการ
ปลูกนั่นแหละ
นะเราก็ต้องมีฝักของอะไรซะก่อนที่มีเมล็ด
เมล็ดม็ดอันนี้นะอาจจะเป็นเมล็ดถั่วนะ
หรือจะเป็นเม็ดก็ได้เนาะอย่างมะม่วงอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยแต่ว่ามะม่วงมันจะต้นใหญ่ค่ะ
อ่าเสร็จแล้วเราก็ต้องเตรียมดินนะอ่า
เพราะฉะนั้นเราก็ต้องมีกระถางแบบนี้ก็ได้
อืใช่เราก็ต้องไปซื้อกระถางซื้อดิน
อืแล้วก็มาทำเป็นหลุมนะเอาเมล็ดเนี่ยค่ะ
หรือเอาเม็ดเนี่ยหยอดลงไปอาจจะ 3-4 เมล็ด
นะเนี่ย 3-4 เมล็ด 1 หลุมเอ้ยอาจจะแยกกัน
ก็ได้ค่ะครูชิมันจะได้ไม่แย่งอาหารแบ่งออ
เอา 1 เม็ด 1 เม็ด 1 เม็ด 1 เม็ดอ่าก็คน
ละมุม 4
มุมนะมันจะได้ไม่แย่งอาหารกันนะเห็นมยเา
จะเสร็จแล้วเราก็เอาดินกบอ่าเห็นมเปลูก
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ติดกันไม่ได้มาจากที่เดียว
กันเห็นมยเจะเว้นช่องว่างนิดนึงนิด
นึงพอเอาดินกบแล้วเราก็คอยลดน้ำทุกวันไม่
ต้องลดเยอะนะไม่ต้องเอาน้ำท่วมเดี๋ยวต้น
ไม้ตายใช่อันนี้น่าจะลดเยอะเกินไปนะคใช่
ค่ะเอาน้ำนิดหน่อยค่ะนะนะอือให้ให้ดินมัน
แบบชื้นๆนะแล้วก็เดี๋ยวไม่นานค่ะมันก็งอก
เป็นต้นใหม่ค่ะอ่าอืต้นอ่อนเนอันนี้เนี่ย
อื้อหือเราเรียกว่าเป็นการขยายพันธุ์ด้วย
การปลูกหรือการเพาะด้วยเมล็ด
อ่านะก็คือเอาเม็ดของต้นไม้นี่แหละไปปลูก
เลยหรือว่าเมล็ดของต้นไม้เนี่ยไปปลูกลง
ดินเลยอือนะอันนี้ก็ง่ายค่ะนะกินเสร็จ
อย่างครูปุมีมะม่วงใช่มั้ยกินมะม่วงเสร็จ
นะครูบุ๊กก็เอาไปใส่ในดินเนาะปลูกในดินอื
นะแล้วก็กลบลงไปรดน้ำ 1 วัน 2 วัน 3 วัน
เดี๋ยวมันก็จะมีต้นอ่อนเล็กๆค่ะมีใบเล็กๆ
ขึ้นมา
น่า
นะแต่เขาบอกว่าการปลูกเนี่ยมันอาจจะมี
วิธีอื่นไงถ้าเกิดบางต้นไม้บางต้นที่ไม่
มีเมล็ดเอ้าอย่างงั้นก็จะปลูกยังไงล่ะคะ
ไม่มีเมล็ดหรือไม่มีเม็ดเนี่ยมันจะปลูก
ได้เหรอกูชิ
ปลูกได้เราก็เอากิ่งค่ะกิ่งกิ่งนักเรียน
ต้องออหนักเรียนก็ต้องรู้จักกิ่งก่อนนะ
ใช่อ่าครูชิเนี่ยก็จะต้องมีต้นไม้ก่อนค่ะ
อ้าูชิไม่เดินออกไปแล้วไป
ขุดเอาตรงนี้ละค่ะอันนี้คือลำต้น
อ่าแล้วอันนี้ก็คือกิ่งค่ะครู
ปุ๊ก
กิ่ง
ก้าน
ใบกิ่งก้านไปเราเอากิ่งเนี่ยค่ะเห็น
มเอากิ่งแบบเนี้ยค่ะมาปลูกได้
โยังไงูชี้พูดเป็นเล่นพูดเป็นเล่นเรา
เรียกการปลูกด้วกิ่งว่าการปัก
ชำทำยังไงคะการปักชำเนี่ยเราก็ต้องมีดิน
ก่อนค่ะนะคะแล้วเราก็เอากิ่งมา
ค่ะเราก็เด็ดใบทิ้งให้เหลือนิดหน่อย 1 ใบ
2 ใบโดยเฉพาะใบอ่อนๆแบบนี้ค่ะเหลือเอา
ไว้นิดหน่อยนะแบบนี้ใบอ่อนๆนะใบเล็กๆแบบ
นี้เก็บเอาไว้เหลือไว้อ่านะแล้วก็ตัดแบบ
เฉียงๆ
นะแบดเฉียง 45 องศค่ะอ่าเราจะได้ไปอ่าเรา
ตัดเฉียงแบบนี้ชึบอ่าไม่ตัดตรงค่ะตัด
เฉียงแล้วเราก็เอาเอาอันเนี้ยค่ะเอาเอาลง
มาเอามาปักที่ดินค่ะปักไว้เลยครูปุ๊กแบบ
นี้อืปักลงไปปักลงไปให้เต็มเลยค่ะนะก็
ห่างกันนิดนึงนะต่อต้นนะก็ปักลงไปอ๋อเเอา
อะไรจิ้มลงไปก่อนนะแล้วก็ค่อยเอาต้นเนี่ย
เสียบลงกกิ่งเนี่ยเสียบลงไปแล้วก็ลดน้ำอื
ไม่ต้องเยอะนะคะไม่ต้องท่วมลดนิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อยให้ให้ให้ดินเนี่ยชื้นๆไม่ใช่เปียก
แต่ชื้นๆมีน้ำอืนะคะอันเนี้ยล่ะค่ะที่เรา
เรียกว่าการปักชำอ้าเสร็จแล้วหรอคะแค่
เนี่ยเสร็จแล้วแล้วเดี๋ยวมันก็จะมีรากงอก
ออกมาไงอ๋อเอรากมันจะงอกจากตรงไหนล่ะคะ
มันไม่มีเม็ด่ะกูชิมันละรากมันจะงอกจาก
ต้นเอ้จากกิ่งเนี่ยค่ะอือย่างอย่างเวลา
เราปักลงไปใช่มั้ยปึ๊กๆอ่าพอเรามีดิน
อย่างงี้รากมันจะออกมาจากนี่ค่ะจากลำต้น
เลยจากกิ่งเลยค่ะ
อืรากมันจะโผล่มาในตรงกิ่งของของมันเลย
ค่ะอแต่เราไม่ต้องรดน้ำให้ทุกวันนะอย่า
ให้ดินแห้งนะฮต้องให้ดินเนี่ยชื้นถูกต้อง
ก็คือมีน้ำแต่ไม่ใช่ชุ่มจนแบบน้ำเยอะเกิน
ไปนะเห็นมั้ยคะออจกิ่งเนี่ยค่ะเห็นมั้ยคะ
จะมีรากรากมันเนี่ยงอกออกมาค่ะแบบนี้ก็
แยกออกมาแล้วไปปลูกได้ค่ะูปุ๊ก
อืมนะก็เอาไปปลูกนะพอมีแรกเสร็จแล้วเราก็
เอาไปลงดินเลยเนาะไม่ต้องอยู่ในกระถาง
เล็กๆไปอยู่ในดินเลยปลูกเป็นต้นใหญ่ๆได้
เลยแต่พืชบางชนิดค่ะครูปุ๊กพืชบางชนิด
เนี่ยเราอาจจะใช้ใบไป
ปักปักชำอาจจะไม่ต้องใช้กิ่งอย่างเดียว
ใช้ใบก็ได้นี่
อโอ
อืเอาใบไปปักเลยค่ะแล้วมันก็จะกลายเป็น
ต้นใหม่
อ๋อก็คือชนิดนี้มันมีใบที่สามารถใช้ขยาย
พันธุ์ได้ใช่มั้ยเอาไปปลูกได้ใชเพราะว่า
มันอาจจะไม่ได้มีกิ่งไงมันอาจจะไม่ได้มี
กิ่งเหมือนกับชนิดอื่นๆเนานะใช่ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กเห็น
มยใช้กิ่งใช้ใบไปเพาะได้นะคะอืหรือบาง
อย่างเนี่ยเราอาจจะไม่มีดินใช่มยเหมือน
แบบวิธีการปลูกหัวหอมเลยครูปุ๊กนะคะเราก็
เอากิ่งเนี่ยค่ะตัดแล้วก็เสียบลงไปในน้ำ
อืเดี๋ยวสักพักนึงตรรงกิ่งมันจะมีรากค่ะ
งอกออกมาแบบนี้ก็คือแช่น้ำไว้เลยใช่มยใช่
ใช่อไม่ต้องมาคอยรดน้ำแล้วก็ดีค่ะนะแช่
ไว้ 1 วัน 2 วัน 3 วันคอยดูเดี๋ยวมันจะมี
รากออกมาใช่มั้ยครููชิแต่ถ้าอยากจะให้ราก
งอกออกมาเร็วครูปุ๊กต้องเปลี่ยนน้ำบ่อยๆ
อ้าทำไมอ่ะเอ้าบางทีมันใช้มันมันเป็น
อาหารของต้นไม้ไปหมดแล้วก็ต้องเทออกไปเอา
น้ำใหม่ค่ะอืมีอาหารใหม่มาให้มันนะแล้ว
มันอาจจะทำจะโตเร็วขึ้นใช่มันอาจจะมีเศษ
อะไรที่ทำให้รากเน่าได้มันอาจจะแบบอทำให้
ต้นไม้ตายเนาะก็เปลี่ยนน้ำใหม่ทุกวันใช่
แต่ว่าต้องแช่ไว้แบบนี้เนาะเดี๋ยวมันก็จะ
มีรากที่งอกออกมาแล้วเราค่อยเอาไปลงใน
กระถางหรือเอาไปลงดินสำหรับปลูกเลยใชถููก
ต้องอันนี้เาเรียกอะไรนะวิธีทำอะไรนะูชิ
ปักชำค่ะปักชำอ๋อปักในดินนก็ได้ปักลงไปใน
น้ำก็ได้เป็นการปักนเหมือนกันอื
[เพลง]
ออันนั้นก็เป็นการขยายพันธุ์แบบนึง
อืยยังค่ะะยังไม่หมดแหมกำลังจะถามว่ามี
อีกมวิธีอื่นมีมั้ยถ้าเกิดไม่มีไม่ไม่ใช้
วิธีนี้เรามีวิธีอื่น
มยจริงๆเนี่ยไอ้ปักชำเนี่ยเราใช้การปักชำ
ได้หลายอย่างนะูปุ๊กนะคอย่างอันเนี้ยเรา
อาจจะตัดเป็นชิ้นๆแล้วก็ไปปปักในดินก็ก็
มีรากงอกขึ้นมาได้นะนะหรืออย่างผักชีใช่
มั้ยผักชีเเนี่ยกินใบหมดแล้วก็เอาตรงราก
เนี่ยไปปักดินค่ะปักชำโดยรากก็ได้ปักชำ
โดยใบก็ได้ใช่มปักชำโดยกิ่งอย่างอะไรล่ะ
สระแหน่อย่างเงี้ยนะคุณเอากิ่งเนี่ยไปปัก
ๆๆๆเป็นต้นใหม่ก็ได้อื
อ่าหรือประเภทที่เป็นหัวๆแบบนี้ตัดค่ะเรา
ไปปักดินก็มีรากออกมาค่ะโอเออ
นะปักชำนี่ใช้ได้หลายอย่างหรือถ้าเป็นแบบ
ลักษณะแบบขิงแบบ
นี้หรือเป็นข่าแบบนี้อืใช่มยค่ะแบบเนี้ย
ตัดแบบนี้เลยค่ะตัดแล้วเอาไปฝังดินก็ขึ้น
เป็นต้นใหม่อนี้ต้องงอกออกมาอ๋ที่มันแง่ง
นึงก็ตัดออกไปเลยใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ไปปักดินตั
มันจะขึ้นต้นมาแบบนี้เลยค่ะเห็นมั้ยฝัง
ดินไปอันนี้ก็เหมือนกันค่ะแยกออกมาค่ะ 1
ปัก 1 ปักเอามา 1 แง่งอ่ะแล้วก็ไปปักเอา
มา 1 แง่งแล้วก็ไปปักนะแต่นักเรียนต้องรอ
มันแก่กว่านี้ก่อนนะอืถ้ามันอ่อนแบบนี้
ยังปักไม่ได้นะมันยังไม่ขึ้นก็เอาขิงที่
เป็นสีน้ำตาลใช่มั้ยขิงแก่ใช่ขิงแก่ขิง
อ่อนเนี่ยมันยังเด็กๆค่ะ
นะเนื้อเยื่อมันยังไม่โตใช่ๆมันยังไม่
พร้อมที่จะมีนะรากหรือว่าอะไรนะก็ต้องรอ
สีีสีสีน้ำตาล
เข้มๆก่อนใช่เห็นมยเราเนี่ยปักชำได้หรือ
กระเทียมอืเอาหัวมันเนี่ยไปปักชำได้ก็
กลายเป็นต้นกระเทียมใหหขึ้นมาเลยอือมันก็
จะมีใบงอกขึ้นมาเนาะใช่ตะไคร้กินหมดแล้ว
ก็เอาก้นมันเนี่ยไปปักชำเป็นต้นตะไคร้
ใหม่ได้เห็นมย
อืใช้ลำต้นปักชำได้ใช้กิปักชำได้ใช้ใบปัก
ชำได้อ
นะหมดแล้ว
เนาะเหง้าหัวของปักชำได้เห็นมยอ้านะหมดึ
ยังคะนอกจากการปักฉ่ำอ่ะยังได้อีกเหรอคะ
ูชิ
มีการขยายพันธุ์แบบใหม่นะเราเรียกว่าการ
ตอนค่ะแนตอนนะใช่ทำยถ้าเราปลูกโดยใช้
เมล็ดมันน่ะมันต้องใช้เวลานานใช่มั้ยแต่
ถ้าคุณเจอต้นไม้ที่อร่อยแล้วเนี่ยอ่า
อย่างเนี้ยมะกรูดต้นเนี้ยลูกใหญ่เม็ดน้อย
อยากจะขยายพันธุ์กิ่งเนี้ยเอากิ่งเนี้ยไป
ปลูกเป็นต้นใหม่เนี่ยเราต้องใช้วิธีการ
ตอนกิ่งเนี่ยเราก็เลือกกิ่งที่ขนาดแบบ
กำลังดีกำลังดีกำลังมีเค้าเรียกอะไรมีตา
ที่กำลังจะงอกใหม่เนี่ยค่ะนะแล้วก็ไม่ไม่
แก่ไม่อ่อนเกินไปนะมันจะมันจะใช้งานได้นะ
นักเรียนค่ะนะเสร็จแล้วใช้มีดค่ะล็อกนึง
เนี่ยห่างประมาณซักเอ่อ 2 ซมครึ่งนะนิ้ว
นึงอ่านิ้วนึงก็ได้อืเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็ลอก
เปลือกออกไปค่ะก็จะเหลือเนื้อไม้นะเนื้อ
ของต้นไม้อเหแกเสร็จแล้วใช่เสร็จแล้วก็
เอามีดขูดๆๆๆค่ะขูดนิดนึงค่ะต้องเอา
เปลือกออกมยครูชิเอาเปลือกออกด้วยค่ะ
เนี่ยเอาเปลือกสีน้ำตาลที่เป็นเปลือกรอบ
รอบนอกเนี่ยออกค่ะเสร็จแล้วก็ขูดตรงเนื้อ
เยื่อนิดนึงมันอาจจะมีอะไรเคลือบเดี๋ยว
ลากมันไม่งอกขูดมันออกนิดนึงอนะเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยเอากาบมะพร้าวค่ะนะเป็นเปลือกของ
มะพร้าวเนาะ
ใช่มาห่อแล้วก็ห่อด้วยพลาสติกอีกที
นึงแล้วก็คอยรดน้ำอย่าลดเยอะเดี๋ยวเน่าอ
นะนะอ่าเอาที่มันนิ่มๆนะนักเรียนตรงข้าง
ในเนาะเปลือกข้างนอกมันจะแข็งเปลือกข้าง
ในมันจะนิ่มแล้วมันจะดูดน้ำเปลือกข้างใน
เนาเนมันจะนิ่มข้างนอกมันเหมือนไม้ค่ะนะ
แล้วก็เอาแค่นิ่มๆมันดึงออกมาแล้วก็เอามา
คลุมได้นะเพื่อให้มีความชื้นไงรากมันจะ
ได้งอกออกมาใช่พอสักพักนึงเห็นมะมัน
อ่ามันก็จะมีรากงอกออกมาใช่มยครูชิใช่ที่
เห็นขาวๆเนี่ยนะคะพอมีรากงอกแบบนี้แล้วก็
ตัดเลยค่ะตัดตรงนี้เลยเอ่อเราจำเป็นต้อง
เอาพลาสติกมาคลุมไว้ไหมไม่ให้ความชื้นมัน
หายไปหมดอ่ะูชิคลุมตั้งแต่แรกแล้วค่ะครู
ปุ๊กตั้งแต่ตอนเนี้ยพอเราพันแล้วเราก็
คลุมด้วยพลาสติกเห็นมยคมีพลาสติกคุมต้อง
รสน้ำเสร็จแล้วเนาะให้มันน้ำมันอยู่ข้าง
ในมันก็จะไม่ระเหยไม่ออกมาข้างมันไม่หาย
ไปเนาะมันก็ยังอยู่ความชื้นก็ยังอยู่ข้าง
ในนะเ็แล้วก็รากรอรากงอกออกมาก็ตัดออกมา
ปลูกเลยนะแต่ปลูกก็ต้องเอาพลาสติกออกมั้ย
ใเอาพลาสติกออกค่ะอ่าเอาพลาสติกออกเดี๋ยว
มันไม่ทะลุเดี๋ยวลากไม่ทะลุพลาสติกแกะ
พลาสติกออกแล้วค่อยไปลงดินลากมันก็จะขยาย
ออกไปอรากนี้มันก็จะแบบขยายออกไปเป็นต้น
ใหม่ที่แข็งแรงขึ้นแล้วก็โตเร็วอูมยมันจะ
เร็วกว่าปลูกด้วยเมล็ดมั้ย
เร็วกว่าค่ะครูปุ๊กอย่างเมล็ดกว่าจะโต
เท่านี้อาจจะใช้เวลา 1 ปี 2 ปีแต่ถ้าตอน
เนี่ย
โอ้ใช้เวลาไม่นาน 1 อาทิตย์ 2 อาทิตย์ก็
ก็เป็นต้นขนาดนี้แล้วและใช้เวลาอีกไม่นาน
บางบางกิ่งอ่ะมันกำลังจะมีลูกอยู่แล้ว
ไงมันก็จะออกลูกได้เร็วเลยค่ะ
ออเหมือนอันนี้เป็นทางด่วนเลยนะใช่ชัดเ
เลยเรียกว่าตอนตัดตอนการโตเสียเวลาค่ะอ่า
คะนะเพราะว่าต้นต้นที่เราตัดมาอายุเท่า
ไหร่ต้นนี้ก็อายุเท่ากันอืนก็ก็ดีนะเร็ว
ดีค่ะเอาอันนี้
ค่ะยังมีอีกค่ะการขยายพันธุ์พืชเนี่ยมี
อีกอ้าต้องทำยังไงคะูชิอันนี้เราเรียกว่า
ต่อกิ่งค่ะต่อกิ่ง
อืมีต้นที่แข็งแรงกับต้นที่เอ่อต้นที่เรา
ต้องการแต่มันไม่ค่อยแข็งแรงอ่ะเราเอา
พันธุ์ที่เอ่อสมมุติสมมุติว่าเอ่อ
อันเนี้ยเป็นอะไรดีอ่ะมะม่วงเป็นมะม่วง
ที่ที่อร่อยแต่ต้นมันไม่ค่อยแข็งแรงแต่
มันมีต้นมะม่วงอีกต้นนึงเนี่ยแข็งแรงมาก
แต่เปรี้ยวไม่อร่อยแต่มันไม่อร่อยนะเราก็
เอากิ่งของต้นอร่อยมาเสียบกับลำต้นของต้น
แข็งแรงเราจะได้อาศัยรากของต้นแข็งแรง
เนี่ยดูดอาหารมาเลี้ยงต้นที่ไม่แข็งแรง
วันนี้อืจะได้ออกผลอร่อยๆให้เรากินอันนี้
เราเรียกว่าต่อกิ่งค่ะเอากิ่งเอากิ่ง
อร่อยต่อกับกิ่งแข็งแรงเราก็จะได้ต้นแข็ง
เอ่อต้นอร่อยและแข็งแรงที่แข็งแรงนะคอัน
นี้เราเรียกว่าต่อกิ่งค่ะนะเป็นการขยาย
พันธุ์อีกอย่างหนึ่งอ๋อก็ดีค่ะอนะนัก
เรียนก็อาจจะมีต้นไม้ต้นนึงแต่ว่าผลมัน
อาจจะไม่เหมือนกันเนอะ
ใช่นอกจากต่อกิ่งแล้วเนี่ยการขยายพันธุ์
อีกอย่างนึเราเรียกว่าทาบกิ่งค่ะทาบกิ่ง
เอากิ่งหนึมาทาบกับอีกกิ่งนึงนะแต่ต้อง
ตัดเฉียงใช่มยตัดเอาเปลือกออกใช่ค่ะต้อง
เอาเนื้อเยื่อของต้นไม้อมาติดกันมันถึงจะ
ติดนะเราจะให้มันรวมกันเป็นต้นเดียวกัน
อ่าแล้วก็ต้นกิ่งที่เราเอามาเนี่ยเห็นมย
กิ่งที่มันเป็นที่เราต้องการเนี่ยมันจะ
ออกเขียวน้ำตาลนะแต่ว่ามันจะไม่ได้เป็นสี
เขียวอ่อนแล้วก็จะไม่ใช่เป็นสีน้ำน้ำตาล
เข้มคือกิ่งมันจะพอดีไม่แก่ไม่อ่อนอืนะ
สังเกตดูตรงต้นตรงที่เราเอามาติดกันเนาะ
มันก็จะเป็นสีเขียวๆน้ำตาลน้ำตาลนะไม่แก่
ไม่
อ่อนอันเนี้ยเราเรียกว่าทาบกิ่งหรือแบบ
นี้เราก็เรียกว่าทาบกิ่งค่ะเอาต้นที่ 1
มาทาบกับต้นที่ 2 ต้องเอาเปลือกออกก่อนนะ
เอาเนื้อกับเนื้อมาชนกันแป๊ะอืมันจะได้
ติดอันนี้จับมันมาแต่งงานกันค่ะแตนแทน
แททแล้วก็มัดให้อยู่ด้วย
กัน
นะอันเนี้ยถ้าเราอยากจะได้ต้นเอ่อเราเรา
เราอยากจะได้กิ่งนี้นะเพราะกิ่งนี้มัน
อร่อยไงแล้วเราจะเอาไปปลูกเราก็เลยต้องพอ
มันโตแล้วเนี่ยเราก็จะตัดกิ่งของมันค่ะ
ออก
อ่าแล้วก็ตัดกิ่งเดิมของมันออกอันนี้เรา
ก็เอาอันนี้ไปปลูก
ค่ะอไปปลูกเป็นต้นใหม่เราก็จะได้ต้นที่
อร่อยอยู่บนต้นใหม่ของเราต้นนี้ก็จะ
เหมือนกับพ่อ
มันต้นต้นต้นแม่เป็นยังไงต้นนี้ก็จะเป็น
เหมือนกันเราไปปลูกก็จะเหมือนต้นนี้เลยนะ
อ่าต้องเอาให้ถูกต้นนะนักเรียนตัดออก
ตัดไม่ถูกต้นนี่แย่เลยนะจะได้ต้นที่ไม่
อร่อยเลยนะ
อ่าใช่มั้ยต้องต้องให้รู้ว่าเราต้องการ
กิ่งของอันไหนนะเราต้องการกิ่งนี้เราก็
ต้องตัดกิ่งที่เราไม่ต้องการออกไปใช่นะ
กิ่งต้นที่ไม่อร่อยก็ไม่เอาค่ะตัดทิ้งเรา
ก็จะเหลือตะกิ่งที่อร่อยไว้นะใช่ค่ะอัน
นี้เราเรียกว่าการทาบกิ่งทากิ่งใช่นะคะ
นอกจากการทาบกิ่งแล้วก็มีการขยายพันธุ์
โดยการติดตาหึ
ตาใช่ค่ะออต้นไม้มีตา
อ่าเราเราจะเอาต้นต้นที่เราคิดว่าแข็งแรง
เนี่ยเป็นเป็นต้นที่มันนกับเป็นพื้นที่
สำหรับปลูกเพราะมันแข็งแรงใช่มยเราก็ต้อง
ผ่าปืมันเป็นตัว T เอาไว้ค่ะนะคะแล้วก็ไป
เฉือนเอาตาค่ะของต้นที่เราอยากจะขยาย
พันธุ์ต้นนี้ต้องเป็นต้นที่อร่อยแน่ๆเรา
ถึงอยากจะขยายมันให้มีเยอะๆ
ค่ะแต่มันอยู่กับต้นมันเนี่ยต้นมันอาจจะ
ไม่แข็งแรงเราก็เอาตาเนี่ยไปติดกับต้นที่
แข็งแรงค่ะก็เสียบเข้าไปในตัว T เนี่ยค่ะ
แล้วก็เอาพลาสติกมาพันเชื่อมให้มันไป
ติดกันปิดเอาไว้ต่อกันอืปิดใช่ให้ตาโผล่
มานะคะไม่ใช่ภูมิพลาสติกหมดเลยนะนะก็คือ
ให้ตัว T เนี่ยมันมันมันหุ้มปิดลงไปเนาะ
แล้วก็เหลือตรงตาที่มันจะออกเป็นกิ่งใหม่
อ่ะให้มันผออกมาใช่ค่ะต้องโผล่ตาเอาไว้
ด้วยนะไม่งั้นเดี๋ยวเราจะไม่ได้เราจะไม่
ได้เอ่อต้นใหม่นะค่ะโอวันนี้ก็ได้มีความ
รู้เยอะเลยอันนี้หมดหรือยังคะคูชิเพราะ
ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยมีการเพาะพันธุ์ที่เขาบอก
ว่าอันเนี้ยต้นแม่เป็นยังไงลูกก็จะเป็น
แบบนั้นเป๊ะแกะ DNA มาเป๊ะๆอันนี้เรา
เรียกว่าการเอาเอาเนื้อเยื่อมาเพาะอืเพาะ
เนื้อเยื่อเห็นมยตัดต้นที่เราคิดว่าอร่อย
อยากจะขยายพันธุ์เนี่ยเอาเนื้อเยื่อมา
แล้วก็มาใส่ในสารเคมีนะให้มันให้มันเกิด
ต้นใหม่ขึ้นมาค่ะค่ะอันนี้เหมือนเหมือ
อะไรนะโคลนิ่งเหรอคะเออเหมอันนี้กึ่ง
วิทยาศาสตร์นิดนึงอ่าเพราะว่าอันนี้จะ
เร็วที่สุดนะมันก็จะเร็วมากขึ้นนะแล้วก็
ขยายพันธุ์ได้เยอะขึ้นคืออันเนี้ยขยาย
พันธุ์ได้เยอะขึ้น 1  2 เนี่ยเหมือนกับ
พ่อพันธุมันไม่เปลี่ยนไปอมันไม่เปลี่ยน
อ่าเพราะว่าพ่อเป็นยังไงพอมาขยายพันธุ์
แล้วมันจะเหมือนกันเด๊ะมันเอาเนื้อเยื่อ
ของคนเนี้ยมาขยายอืนะคต้นเนี้ยมาขยายนะค
มันไม่เหมือนเอาไปปลูกนะปลูกบางทีอาจจะมี
เม็ดที่แบบแข็งแรงเม็ดไม่แข็งแรงอาจจะต้น
อร่อยไม่อร่อยนะมันไม่เหมือนกับกัน
เออเื้อเยออืค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็ได้รู้
จักเนาะนะวิธีการขยายพันธุ์ของต้นไม้นะ
เราอยากได้ต้นไม้ที่มันอร่อยแล้วก็อยากจะ
ปลูกด้วยวิธีไหนเนาะนะก็สามารถทำได้ถ้า
นักเรียนแบบเอ๊ยจำไม่ได้ย้อนกลับไปดูใหม่
ค่ะดูหลายๆครั้งนะคะก็จะได้ภาษาเกี่ยวกับ
การขยายพันธุ์ต้นไม้เรียกอะไรเพราะเมล็ด
ต่อกิ่งทาบกิ่งติดตาปักชำคืออะไรนะค่ะนะ
วันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะนะนักเรียนน่ะนะ
อยากให้อยากรู้อะไรก็เขียนคอมเมนต์มาแล้ว
กันนะคะค่ะวันนี้เรา 2 คนเนี่ยต้องลาไป
ก่อนล่ะค่ะแล้วเรามาพบกันใหม่นะคะวันนี้
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพบกันใหม่โอกาสหน้า